[Music]
Red Dead Redemption too has an extensive
in-game help section full of tips and
tricks but there's a lot in the game you
aren't explicitly told thanks to game
spots hundreds of cumulative hours in
the game we can clue you into a few now
some of these you may have come across
some possibly not so let's find out
I know you wanna rub stores and hijack
wagons but trust me on this one it's
really worth paying attention to the
story and that includes the many side
missions with your fellow gang members
some of the best moments in this game
are totally optional observed
conversations in camp which ultimately
informed the larger story moments you'll
come across in the main narrative
through lied the side quests associated
with fellow gang members are almost
always fun and interesting and don't
outstay their welcome
while the stranger missions that are
identifiable with white markers on the
map usually introduce you to some of the
most colorful and hilarious characters
in the game including my personal
favorite Charles chattin a these white
markers side missions can expire if you
advance the yellow marker main missions
too far so keep that in mind
if you're ready for a menial task or
ready for a fight both of which should
get you a nice handful of cash keep your
eye out for rising smoke trails out in
the wilderness these trails tend to be
indicators of points of interest heading
to the source should help you stumble on
travelers offering up tips strangers who
need help or just rivals looking to put
a hole in your skull check out your
character sheet in the player submenu to
see what weight class you fall into
whether Arthur is underweight average or
overweight
there are buffs and debuffs associated
with both extremes a larger Arthur can
absorb more damage while a more live
Arthur can maintain stamina for longer
weight will increase with more sedentary
actions and eating more snacks and
lessons with exercise yep just like real
life
if your inventory is getting clogged
with wedding rings pilfered off the
corpses of people who tried to cross you
you're going to need a fence these shady
merchants can be found in locations
including Rhodes emerald ranch and
Santini fences also sells support items
throwable weapons and recipes and can
also craft rare talismans and trinkets
there are also fencers who pay cash for
stolen horses and wagons and a certain
side mission will enable the post office
worker in Rhodes to dole out tips on
which wagons of worth robbing
during combat particularly with annoying
by TBC's tap square on ps4 or exon Xbox
one while aiming to combat roll out of
the way that's all there is to say about
this one but it is super handy Red Dead
Redemption 2 may give you GTA vibes but
it's important to note that hijacking a
horse is way harder than hijacking a car
horses don't take kindly to someone
other than their owner hopping on all
rifling through their saddlebags so make
sure you calm stream choices before
touching them or expect a kick to the
gizzards a hard one sure you can shoot
up dudes with any old gun but if your
Arthur is a stylish kind of guy you
might want to customise your weaponry
add a gunsmith you can alter the metals
the paint the varnish the woodwork
engravings you name it if you're more
practical altering things like the
barrels and sights can actually improve
the stats of the gun while wrapping will
help reduce degradation it's only a
handful of dollars for each modification
so if you have a favorite piece go for
it also double tapping your holster
makes arthur's spin the gun before he
puts it away and that makes you look
pretty cool
I'm loving Red Dead Redemption too but I
have to be honest there's nothing worse
than finishing a mission checking your
results screen and seeing that crummy
bronze medal and all the objectives you
missed luckily you can replay missions
at any point so if you want to relive a
cool moment or go for gold you can
totally do that
with a hundred and seventy eight animals
to keep an eye out for hunting may seem
a little daunting but there are ways to
make sure you aren't wasting your time
wildlife is divided into three groups
poor good and perfect if that camp
upgrades you want calls for a perfect
Longhorn skin make sure you study the
animal at a distance first to check its
quality and take note of the clues of
how best to hunt it if you do take out a
legendary animal the materials and rare
items will be automatically transferred
to fences and trappers aiming for vital
areas with a bow will get you a clean
kill and a nice much less ruined skin
than if you run over it with your horse
the latter is much funnier however
if you want to delve completely into the
Wild West wilderness you may like to
turn off that pesky HUD if you do go
ahead with that just make sure you
listen to the instructions NPCs give you
when you're being asked to direct them
places oh you'll get very lost very
quickly you'll also need to note where
gunshots are coming from as you won't be
able to see enemy indicators without the
HUD on
the original title for this section in
our GameSpot tips gallery is take down
the big targets with ease but given the
further with which my housemate yelled
out that's cheating while seeing me get
captured for this section I've renamed
it basically shooting is hard but
lassoing is way easier you can quickly
hog-tie people by running up to them
with the lasso equipped and pressing r2
to end fights instantly for Faunus so
long as the animal is not too big and
not too little you can just lasso it and
chop it with your dagger for a nice
clean kill don't try this on an
alligator it won't work and you'll get
so scared you have to take off your
headphones while watching Arthur get
death roll
Wild West GTA unsurprisingly lets you
turn arthur into a good guy or a real
bad guy as a nice guy you'll get sweet
store discounts and right cheerier diary
entries around all your cute scribbles
as a meanie killcams get more violent
responses to nbc's are more snide and
your journal is a tad more [ __ ] if you
want to get a good guy points you can
mosey around town saying howdy to
everybody and turning down rewards and
if you want to be bad well I'm sure you
can figure that one out if you've been
playing Red Dead Redemption 2 for more
than 5 minutes you've probably noticed
that falling off your horse is a wildly
common occurrence aside from the
embarrassment and bruises if you were
stirring game or heights on your horse
just be sure to pick them up off the
ground before taking off again as they
will have fallen during your untimely
tumble
if you want to fish to the best of your
ability make sure you're using the
correct bait and lures for the location
you'll end that your technique is
correct and that you're fishing at the
right time of day just like in real life
early morning and afternoon tend to
produce the best fishy results fishing
during a rainstorm also increases the
activity of aquatic animals let us know
if there's any great Red Dead Redemption
2 tips you've uncovered that we missed
out on in that comment section and check
back to all our red dead content
including our brand new show quick draw
[Music]